I
are you happy prove it if you're happy
and you know it clap your hands if
you're happy and you know it clap your
hands if you're happy and you know that
you really want to show it if you're
happy and you know it clap your hands
there's one single thing that you may
want to take home is that people are
happier when they're doing things
together and that's what you've just
done it isn't I was singing to you isn't
that you were singing to yourself is
that we were singing people it's
extraordinarily important but it's what
is lost in so much of conventional
approaches to the disciplines we embody
in this research if you take all the
living material in the world's oceans
and you can put them on a giant balance
you can put everything that you're
familiar with let's take the fish will
take the whales will take the seaweed
will take well anything that you can
name and will put it on one side of the
scale and then we'll just take the
bacteria and we'll put out in the other
side of the scale just the bacteria by
weight we're not talking numbers by
weight would be ninety-five percent of
the living material in the world's
oceans and if we throw the protists in
there those other little things that
swim around r up to ninety eight percent
so everything that we're familiar with
in the oceans is two percent of the
living material by weight i'm not
talking about my numbers i'm talking
about my weight in the world's oceans
we live in a world in which still every
the one person one child mostly dies
every 3.6 seconds in this world because
of a lack of food and water and so if
we're living with this you know why she
would be really worried about co2
emissions when we could actually commit
money to these problems which I think
you could arguably say are really the
biggest problems in the world today and
probably in our children's time they'll
still be some of these problems which
beg for attention I think I as many
others have done I've wrestled with us a
lot and it's really the answer is kind
of simple to me and it's what's listed
here that you can't separate the state
of the environment in the state of the
earth from the state of the world from
the human condition because again it
pervades everything how far can
electrons take us and to make my case I
will give you the last big answer not
the next big question but the last big
answer to that question and that's a
transistor all of you I'm sure
appreciate how physicists like myself
interested in what electrons do when
they figured out with electrons doing
semiconductors in the 1940s invented the
transistor a very simple device
extremely simple device completely
understood that the last decimal point
now when they invested that transistor
they started a revolution that has now
given us 50 60 years later Google the
internet the entire information
technology revolution
the superconductor so the superconductor
is to the transistor what the laser is
to a light bulb super conductivity is
the coherent form of electricity and if
we can do all the things that we can do
with an incoherent transistor imagine if
you can I'm not sure I can imagine what
the coherent version of that might be
let me in close and finish by perhaps
suggesting that more it's not so much a
matter of the size of the question but
the impact of the answer thank you very
much
you